[Applause]
thank you very much Mr wals De John for
the invitation and thank you for the
outstanding job you do here at
Hudson in the 20 years since Hudson
moved to
DC you have become an incredible
authoritative source of ideas and anal
is not only here in Pennsylvania Avenue
but also for us on the other side of the
Atlantic your positions from the support
to Israel to keeping Ukraine on the path
of
Victory from artificial intelligence to
China constantly reach European capitals
and influence our
conversations your track record of
mapping out unbiased solutions to the
world's most complex challenges is in
the image of your Founders and I want to
start in particular by paying tribute to
the late Max
finger the vision he outlined in his
great work history of the
future is one that Europe and the United
States have been fighting for the last
seven decades it is a vision of a modern
world in which democracy and
freedom security and opportunity
education and wealth all become
Universal the events of the last weeks
in the Middle East and of the last years
in Eastern Europe epitomize that this
fight has never gone away in fact it is
more acute than
ever what is at stake here dwarves what
is in front of us in these difficult
days we are shaping the history of our
future and I believe Europe and the
United States have a duty to mold that
future
together there's one old memory that I
would like to share with you it was in 8
1987 and I lived in West
Germany back then it was Unthinkable for
most people to imagine that the Berlin
wall could
fall but not for a Visionary leader like
President
wagan I remember vividly when he came to
Berlin and called Mr gorbachov tear down
this
wall I remember how much he
touched all hearts in
Germany and wagan never stopped working
for exactly that dream he believed and I
quote
the Atlantic Community is the house of
democracy and for him this meant that we
must and I quote again shelter democracy
from all the winds that
blow ladies and gentlemen the winds are
not just blowing
today today they are gale
force our democracies are under
sustained and systemic attack by those
who uphor
freedom because it threatens their
rule for more than 600 days now our
friends in Ukraine have been fighting
and
dying for their freedom against Russian
aggression and now Israel has suffered
the worst terrorist attack in its
history and the worst mass murder of
Jews since the
Holocaust these two
crisis however different call on Europe
and America to take a stand and to stand
together vadir Putin wants to wipe
Ukraine from the map
Hamas supported by Iran wants to wipe
Israel from the
map shelter democracies we
must because if we don't the horror will
spread the horror that I witnessed last
Friday when I was in Israel in Kar
AA 6 days before I visited it was a
lively kibo with 750
inhabitants but on October
7th Hamas
came at 6:00 a.m. in the
morning I saw burned out
houses a baby seat covered with blood
debris bu bullet holes unexploded
grenades it was a ghost
town there was no limit to the blood
Hamas terrorists wanted to spill they
went home by
home they burned people
alive they mutilated children and even
babies and
why because they were
Jews because they were living in the
state of Israel
and hamas's explicit goal is to
eradicate Jewish life from the Holy
Land these terrorists supported by their
friends in Teran will never
stop and so Israel has the right to
defend itself in line with humanitarian
law and in the face of this
horror there's only one possible
response from democratic nations like us
we stand with
[Applause]
Israel I have visited Israel many times
in my
life but this time I saw a nation
shocked to its
core and from the families of the
abducted to president huk prime minister
Netanyahu and right across the unity
government
they all had the same
request
solidarity and clear
words and this is the least we can do
for the people of Israel as Defenders of
a free world where hate Terror and
anti-Semitism have no
place the Palestinian people are also
suffering from Hamas
Terror and there is no
contradiction in standing in solidarity
with
Israel and acting on the humanitarian
needs of
Palestinians we have tripled our
humanitarian support to Palestinians in
Gaza but we are also reviewing all our
development Aid to palestinia in view of
a very
volatile situation on the
ground and we are redoubling our
engagement in the
region we have seen the Arab streets
fill with rage all across the region so
the risk of a regional spill over is
real and this is exactly what Hamas was
hoping to
achieve and this can derail the recent
and historic
R between Israel and its Arab
neighbors a normalization of relations
could offer peace prosperity and
integration into a troubled Nation
region and just weeks ago for instance
we
announced together with our American
friends a new
transcontinental
Corridor that would link Europe to
Israel to Jordan to Saudi
Arabia the
Emirates and from there to
India a corridor for
trade that would help drisk all all our
economies including from our over
dependence on China but also Corridor
for data a corridor for clean energy to
create good jobs all across the Middle
East it could contribute to both growth
and Reconciliation between
neighbors this is the other side of the
possibilities the benefits of a stable
Middle East are
obvious
but there are those who seek more
violence because they know the cost of
any instability for
us Iran Hamas Patron only wants to fuel
the fire of
chaos Russia Iran's wartime customer is
watching
carefully Russia and Hamas are alike as
president zalinski has said their
Essence is the
same both have deliberately sought out
innocent civilians including babies and
children to kill and take
hostage this is a barbaric way to
fight and left unchecked this contagion
has the potential to spread from Europe
across the Middle East and to the
indo-pacific
Western resolve is being tested every
day by those searching for any
weakness any success they gain will
inspire more violence aimed at upending
the existing
order an order that so many lives on our
continents were sacrificed to created
and uphold
it but escalation is not
inevitable and inability can be
contained dialogue between Israel and
its neighbors can and must
continue I've been recently talking to
several Arab leaders including the King
of Jordan the president of the UAE and
the president of
Egypt this time of war must also be a
time of unrelenting
diplomacy Europe has the largest foreign
investor in many countries across the
region has both
leverage and a stake
and the same is true for the United
States it is a shared American and
European
interest the pursuit of a world where
Freedom
prevails is our common
Destiny which is why it is imperative
that we speed up Ukraine's path to
Victory ladies and gentlemen Ukraine
will
[Applause]
win but they need the hardware to get
the job done and we must deliver it to
save lives to bring an end to this
conflict to help regenerate Ukraine
whose Warriors will be proud Defenders
inside
NATO but now it's up to us in the west
to help make that happen as fast as
possible possible and I'm proud that
Europe and the United States have been
leading on this
together Putin has made three major
strategic
mistakes
first he was convinced he would take ke
in a matter of days well Ukraine's
courage showed him
otherwise
second he expected Europe to be hesitant
and
undecided but we were fast determined
unwavering on day two of the war we
imposed wave after wave of sanctions and
up to today we have 11 pack packages of
sanctions and all this in close
cooperation and constant coordination
with the United
States we opened our doors for over 4
million ukrainians fleeing Putin's bombs
and to this day we provide them with
access to education
to Health Care social
protection so far we have supported
Ukraine with close to $90
billion of which 27 billion doar in
military
assistance and like never before in the
history of international Aid we have
been coordinating our assistance with
the United States and other key Partners
in the
G7 to make sure it is complimentary and
address is Ukraine's most pressing
needs and we have already started the
process required for Ukraine to become a
member of the European
Union Putin's third big strategic
mistake was to believe that he could
blackmail Europe with
energy it's true before the war most of
our gas supply was delivered by gas prom
this was a heavy
dependence but then Putin cut 80% of the
gas supplies in 8 months
only so we were in a severe energy
crisis but thanks to our friends in the
United States and Norway for example we
were able to
diversify to get rid of our dependency
on Russian gas in record
time we saved
energy 20% during this winter so we got
our house in order and stood strong and
United against
Putin because of
that we were able to move on and one
thing is clear that autocrats only
understand one language and that is the
language of strength and the language of
unity ladies and
gentlemen we can never match the
sacrifice
and The Bravery of the Ukrainian
people but we can stand firmly by their
side and that's what we're doing for as
long as it
takes not only because it is the right
thing to
do but because they are fighting for our
values and for our strategic
security so we must support Ukraine to
make this war unsustainable for Russia
and together we can can do this and we
must because we know how Russia deals
with war that it cannot win on the
ground it tries to freeze
them just like it did with Ukraine in
2014 and then it waits for the right
moment to launch a new
offensive and here in this room many
voices warned us of this at the time now
we are living that in reality
Putin is playing the same waiting game
counting on us diverting our attention
and our resources
elsewhere so there can be no room for
hesitation or half measures now is the
time to Double Down whether on finance
or
equipment to make sure that the cost of
the war for Russia keeps
rising and to deter those with
intent who are watching us to see if our
endurance can match
theirs this is why our sanctions are
here to
stay and this is why we have broken free
for good of our dependency on Russian
fossil
fuels any solution of this conflict must
be a lasting one and a just and Lasting
peace for
Ukraine and for this Ukraine needs
long-term security
guarantees many of you will be familiar
with the concept of deterrence by
denial it is the idea of providing
Ukraine with the military equipment it
needs to deter Russia and Russian
attacks in the
future I am immensely grateful to the
United States for your Military Support
to
Ukraine you've given strength to the
courage of ukrainians
and I want Europe to play a central role
in ensuring Ukraine's long-term
security for this we have to step up our
defense spending and our industrial base
and we have already
started with the first investment to
ramp up our am ammunition production
capacity I believe that this work should
happen in Synergy with the United States
our oldest and strongest Ally
Ukraine's Ukraine dream Ukraine dreams
of being in Europe and in NATO because
it knows what it stands
for NATO and the European Union are
standing for
security for freedom for
Prosperity president zinsky once said
and there's one thing above all that
motivates Ukrainian Soldier
it is the expectation that one day they
and their children will live in a free
and prosperous country like
ours so if we want Ukraine to
win if we want Ukraine to Rise From the
Ashes of this war we must invest in
Ukraine's future starting
today and Europe is already Leading The
Way with more than 50 billion in
investment for Ukraine to be spent over
the next four
years Europe intends to step up and has
been ramping up its assistance to
Ukraine we recognize that the United
States support should be one important
piece of a global
effort and we are asking other
International investors public and
private to also chip in to give Ukraine
the certainty they need to rebuild to
modernize and to win this
war and this is what we mean when we say
that we are with Ukraine for as long as
it
takes ladies and gentlemen allow me to
finish where I
started what Europe and the United
States are fighting for
together is about
freedom and democracy
it is about security and
opportunity not just for those in active
War zones but for our own
societies we have not forgotten that in
World War II democracy won over Fascism
and
autocracy and this Triumph set our
foundation for our peace
order and this is not only about the
past
but it will also Define our
future and that is why I believe it is
the right thing for the United States to
renew financial and Military Support to
Keith and that is why I believe it is
the right thing for Europe to keep its
own support
up the people in Ukraine are willing to
die for our common
values they have been doing so for over
six 100
days together we have powered their
resistance and this is the transatlantic
partnership at its best a partnership
for freedom for peace for
Prosperity a partnership for shared
values and to go back to Max Zinger I
believe it is once again our duty for
Europe and the United States to help
shape the history of the future thank
you very much for your attention I'm
looking forward to the
cash thank
you